hello everyone and welcome to the other
semi-final match that I said that we
will cover it is Magnus Carlson versus
Fabiano corana and this is the
Armageddon game and it's very
interesting how it got the Armageddon
game because first two games ended in a
draw and then Magnus won the third game
and going into game four he said that he
only needs a draw and he wins the match
and it's like playing Armageddon because
he had the black pieces in game four he
he said it's like playing Armageddon but
with having the full 15 minutes on the
clock uh and you only need to draw with
the black pieces however Fabby uh
completely destroyed him in that game
and he was able to force the Armageddon
game so now uh Magnus gets white in
Armageddon as fabbi out bid him by two
seconds Magnus bid 10 minutes on the
clock and fabbi bid 9 minutes and 58
seconds so now fabbi gets to play for a
draw this game let's see if now Magnus
can retaliate as now to win the match he
needs to win with the white pieces and
uh since he won the first match if the
second one is won by Fabby then they go
into a third one like Wesley had against
nck so that being being said let's check
out the two old rivals meet again uh how
it went Magnus with the white pieces
opens with Pawn to E4 we have Pawn to E5
Knight F3 Knight to C6 and now Bishop to
B5 D Lopez is on the board we have A6
morphe's defense probably you expect the
Berlin defense as Fabi only needs a draw
but Fabi knows that Magnus knows that
Fabi only needs a draw so probably
Magnus has some some specialty in store
for the Berlin defense so he looks for
his chances in morphy's defense we have
Bishop to A4 Knight to F6 we have
castles and Knight captures on e4 so
standard open rule Lopez we have Pawn to
D4 first and now B5 is standard Bishop
to E7 a little less played but still
considered the main line we have Rook to
E1 attacks the Knight and now Pawn to B5
attacking the bishop Bishop to A4 even
though you could go for the trade um
with with Rook captures on E uh E4 then
D5 it's a very well-known line uh it's
best to just move the bishop Bishop to
B3 and now Pawn to D5 we have D captures
on E5 and Bishop to E6 and okay it's a
very standard game we have C3 and now
castles we have H3 uh Queen to D7 and
now Bishop to C2 and this is a very
interesting position because the
position was already reached in
2006 uh between two 1900 players where
Knight B to D2 was played and
interestingly Knight B to D2 is sort of
the top move recommended by the engine
but here uh we have Bishop to C2 and it
is now as of move 12 that we have a
complete completely new game so how does
Fabby meet this idea well of course he
has to do something about the Knight so
he goes Rook a to d8 he says all right
if you want you can capture on e4 it's
not a problem because if you capture I
can just capture back and if Queens get
traded over the ball let a queen
captures Rook captures your knight is
now hanging and once you move the Knight
I can collect on E5 so that's the idea
behind Rook eight to d8 so Magnus just
continues developing Knight beat to D2
and now knight uh Knight captures on D2
Queen captures on D2 q and Bishop to F5
Fabby happily offers a trade of Bishops
and Magnus not only accepts the trade of
Bishops but also offers the immediate
trade of Queens Queen to F4 and Fabby
says all right let's trade uh let's see
you win this end game and he executes
Pawn to D4 which means that further
trades are coming but now Magnus plays
Rook 8 to C1 and he says the real
weakness in your position is the C7 pawn
and that's what we are playing against
so Fabby quickly uh tries to trade off
the C7 Pawn for the A2 Pawn he plays D
captures on C3 Rook captures and Knight
to B4 says okay you capture here I'm
going to capture on A2 okay Rook
captures on C7 and now we have Rook F to
E8 now uh it seems like uh uh before
capturing on z7 like let's say you play
Pawn to A3 you you want to save your
Pawn sorry about that my my phone is
listening to what I'm saying uh then
Knight D5 just wins you the game of
course you cannot allow that so so
that's why Magnus first captured on C7
but now Fabby has to decide because now
if he goes Knight to D5 yes he attacks
the rook and the bishop but the Rook
just moves and now if you capture the
bishop also Rook captures the the bishop
on E7 so instead after Rook captures
here Rook F to8 defending the bishop and
now Bishop to G5 Magnus offers a trade
of Bishops Fabby goes for it captures
captures and this is the position now
Magnus for the moment up a pawn how can
he play this well it's an extremely
complicated position and well puby still
does have 5 minutes and 49 seconds on
the clock he does not find the correct
continuation I'm going to show it to you
because it's um uh it's a lot of fun not
not capturing on A2 the idea is Knight
to D3 you go after the rook and the E5
Pawn so that's the idea here and now if
you move the Rook of course just Knight
captures an E5 but the real line to
calculate is Pawn to E6 so how do you
meet with this of course now you can't
touch the Rook because this is just uh
crushing so you have to play Pawn to F6
and now E7 attacks The Rook here and
once The Rook moves now you move the
rook and you attack the Knight so now
you collect on B2 okay you win your Pawn
back uh and now Rook to d8 and the only
way to play this is um well let's you
take the Knight if you take the Knight
you're just going to lose the game Rook
C to D7 and there's no defense here just
Rook captures followed by the other Rook
coming to d8 even King to F7 doesn't
help you're just going to capture here
and then after Rook captures Rook to d8
and now you're either trading Rooks or
you bring a Queen into the game so of
course completely winning so the only
move you will have here after this Rook
to d8 move uh is not capturing the
Knight it's actually just going for a
capture Rook captures here and once the
queen comes into the game you will
capture the queen and now you will bring
the Knight to E6 pressuring the G7 pawn
and now after let's say Rook to D1
checking H2 we'll play G5 save your pawn
and you're still in the game so that's
that's the idea however after this
Knight to G5 move capture Fabby did not
go for Knight to D3 first he went for F6
six first and it seems like okay same
idea you can play Knight to D3 later on
but now he's just going to be down a
move and now Magnus plays Knight to F7
and the problem is it comes with an
attack on The Rook so you're not in time
to bring the Knight to D3 so Faby first
played Rook to D2 but now Magnus played
Pawn to E6 and the Knight is defended
the pawn is defended everything is
defended uh what do you play uh it's a
very very tricky position and not not a
lot of good moves here H pretty much
everything Lo not pretty much everything
loses for Fabby here it's only a matter
of how Magnus does it so here Pawn to H5
was played and now there's uh well there
are many good moves but there's one move
that's really crushing for Magnus so
feel free to pause the video and try to
spot it it's not an easy one to find so
if you commit really do
commit so uh for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations on
spotting this beautiful move and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show it is Rook to E4 that's the move
Rook to E4 as it comes with a Tempo on
the Knight and next you want to bust
open the position with G4 then you can
play something like captus and then you
have incredible pressure on that G7 Pawn
so that's the way to do it with losing
as little time as possible so not a lot
of great ideas for Faby here he played
Knight captures on A2 and now well you
could go for G4 the move that I
described Magnus goes for Rook to C6
first this also defends these pawn and
he wants to collect on A6 so it's a bit
of a different way of doing things but
still uh very much um uh works and if
you play Pawn to A5 to try and defend
the pawn then just Knight D6 also one of
the reason why Rook to C6 was so strong
because it defends the Knight here uh
The Rook is attacked and once you move
the Rook just Knight F5 and once you
move the Rook now Rook to C7 and that's
all there is the pawn is attacked if you
play G5 now just Knight to G7 attacks
The Rook you move the rook and then E7
E8 wins the game so uh also one of the
ideas behind Rook to C6 so fabbi of
course cannot allow this he played Rook
to D5 and now Magnus could go for the
exact same idea with Knight to D6 but uh
Magnus just now collects on A6 with an
attack on the Knight Knight to C1 and
now Rook to D6 he wants to trade Rooks
here so Rook to C5 Fabby avoids it and
now Rook to D7 uh we have Knight to B3
and now Knight to D6 attacking The Rook
guarding the E7 square with the rook and
now E7 E8 are coming so here tries Rook
to C1 check one last tactical idea King
to H2 and now Knight to D2 trying to
offer his Rook seemingly for The Rook on
e4 but not really here would be a
terrible terrible mistake to go after
the Rook because if Magnus captures The
Rook fobby doesn't take on e4 fobby
plays Knight F1 check and now uh it's a
draw H King to G1 Knight to G3 check
forces a Perpetual King H2 again a G3 is
covered you have to go back uh Fabby
would win the Armageddon game with a
nice Perpetual here so Magnus played
Pawn to G4 he freed up the G3 and G2
squares for his King and now not a lot
for Fabby to do here he played Knight
captures and E4 but now just Knight
captures on E8 going after the G7 Pawn
as well so Rook to E1 you have to put
the Rook behind the pass pawn and now
even Pawn to E7 not even rushing with
captur on G7 Pawn to F5 and now we have
Pawn to G5 by Magnus and the problem is
if you play G6 now then the problem is
Knight to F6 check the Knight is
attacked or if you if you just move the
king then just E8 Queen and if you trade
you get a nice defended pass Pawn here
if King F7 just Rook d8 followed by Rook
to f8 check and then uh promoting the
pawn to a queen will uh will get the job
done so fa played Knight captur and G5
but now Magnus played Knight captur and
G7 and he was in this position on move
36 that Fabiano corana resigned the game
as there is nothing more to be done here
he finished the game with 18 seconds on
the clock but the position is um just a
dead lost uh there's no defense against
against the d8 it will win the rook and
um if you capture the Knight of course
E8 Queen comes with a check from The
Rook here and you will very very quickly
get checkmated something like Queen to
f8 check you're going to go here Queen
to D6 check you have to go to E4 Rook E7
check King F3 and let's say queen to G3
will be Checkmate but any of the other
lines also get the the black king
checkmated uh so yeah very nicely done
by Fabby winning that game four uh
forcing forcing an Armageddon game and
he was very very very close to actually
drawing but he here it was all uh you
know uh it all came down to this F6 Pawn
push uh it's always you know whenever
you want to play F6 regardless of the
position just remember the all saying
you know never play Pawn to F6 even if
it's the strongest move it's still not
uh because here it is but you have to
first play Knight to D3 but of course
yeah it's armag again a little time on
the clock who who can see everything uh
so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it Magnus wins the semi-finals
and he will now face Wesley so in the
finals we'll see what happens it's going
to be it's always great when Magnus
faces Wesley in the finals anyone can
win like I said regardless of who is
playing Magnus Magnus always has a
slight age be Edge because he's Magnus
you know he just has you know if he was
a if he was like a like a collectible
card he would have like a plus one
because you're Magnus you know just like
that uh but yeah hope you enjoyed that I
would like to thank Robert taru and
Sam's giant tortois farm the Night
Before Christmas good luck un lost
school finals canv and Benjamin hyberger
for your contribution to my channel
thank you a lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of this
wonderful event with the finals between
Magnus and Wesley uh thank you all I
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your
day